[موسيقى]
قريه صغيره تقع وسط فرنسا تخفي بين
ثناياها بعضا من الاسرار العائليه اللذيذه
انصح القول مطعم الصغير واحد من تلك
الاسرار حاصل على نجمه ميشنه التقديريه
لفن الطبخ عائله دالي تقف
خلف صندوق اربعه اجيال اثنان من محاري
سانجاك ورز وقطعه من لحم الخنزير اليوم
يحمل فابريس مش على مواصله المشوار في هذا
المطبخ الذي يعرف خباياه جيدا اذ كان
صغيرا عندما كنت صغيرا كنت احضر الكعكه
وبعض الحلويات وكانت امي تحب ذلك جيدا الا
انني كنت اكسر صحون كثيرا فكان علي ان
اتوقف قليلا بدات بعدها اطبخ قليلا لكنني
سعانه ما توجهت الى عالم الحلويات
والمعجنات لانني طالما احببت تحضيرها هذه
الحلوى مثلا قديمه قمت بتحضيرها قبل 20
سنه ضمن احدى المنافسات الفرنسيه لم تكن
الوصفه طبعا مثل الان فقد طورتها وادخلت
عليها بعض التعديلات الحديثه انها نوع من
التيراميس والممزوج بكريمه الجبن الابيض
وجبنه والبسكويت المنقوع في القهوه وقطعه
من الشوكولاته
بعد ان امضى طفولته في هذه المنطقه توجه
الشاب الى باريس ليسقل موهبته في فن الطبخ
وتعلم على ايدي مدربين كبار في عالم الطهي
السبق في سيده من الارز مع قليل من لحم
الماعز المطهي بالزبده والمتبل بنبات
الكرفس ام انت سيدي فاليك قطعه من لحم
الخنزير المغموس في الطماطم وقليل من
الملفوف والبطاطا المهروسه
وماذا ستضع بداخله تضع عصير البازلاء مع
شيء من الكريمه لاطفاء مذاق حامض مع قليل
من الحلوى حسنا قبل فابريز كان ابوه جاكي
هو الذي يسير هذا المطعم رغم تقاعده يظل
الطباخ الماهر السابق دائما بجوار ابنه
يقضي خمس ساعات في الاسبوع هنا بشغف
الماضي نفسه
لابد ان اشغل نفسي قليلا هل الوقت مناسب
للخروج الى البستان اليوم انا لست انسانيا
نوعا ما لكن يجب ان اشغل نفسي
صرت بطيئا في عملي كما اني استغرق وقتا
اطول في قراءه الجريده لم اعد نهائيا
اتكفل باستبدال المصابيح المحترقه واصلاح
الحنفيات المنكسره تعقب ابدا بكل هذا اقوم
فقط بالطبخ ذلك
وحين لا يساعد ابنه في المطعم يقوم جاكي
بزياره امه لوسيان
نحن هنا
مرحبا زكي بدا كل شيء معها كيف حالك بخير
يا جميله رجعنا الى هنا عام 1960 ولم تكن
لدينا
شيئا فشيئا ادخلت عليها الطبخ المنزلي حين
استقبل عمالا او ممثلين
مع بدايه ثمانينيات حمل جاكي على عاتقه
مسؤوليه المطعم مع المحافظه على الاصاله
العائليه وصل العمل على ما قاموا به من
قبل بمعنى ضمن تلك الحاله كان هناك مطعم
صغير تقدمها طبقا يوميا كما ربيع اسطوانات
الغاز كان لدينا مفارش ورقيه واخرى من
القماش من تصميم فيشي تحصلنا على الدرجه
الرابعه عشره والخامسه عشره من تقدير ليس
ذلك فحسب وصل المطعم مشوار التالق حتى حصد
عام
1989 نجمه الفاخره تقديرا لجوده طبخه بعد
ذلك حقق المطعم العائلي قفزه نوعيه من حيث
عدد الزبائن
[موسيقى]
تحدثت من نجمه الاولى
كان ذلك جنونيا
كان ذلك طبعا بعيدا عن ما كانت تطبخه
ليسيان من اطباق بسيطه في عده كانت تقوم
بتحضير الفطائر لزبائنها وتضع لهم خيطا
رقيقا بداخلها تلك الفطائر بمجرد ان
تاكلها تخرج ذلك الخيط مباشره
بعدها ضمن المطاعم الفاخره صفحه جديده
تفتح في تاريخ هذا المشوار العائلي الذي
نزل من دون شك يملك صفحات اخرى للنجاح
التي تبحثين عن وجبتك ابنه من العمر 15
عاما تود ان تصبح نادله شهيه طيبه اما
ابنه 19 عاما فهو الاخر وقع منذ صغره في
سحر عالم الطبخ يتابع حاليا تخصصا يمكنه
من الحصول على شهاده مهنيه في الطبخ
المحافظه على الارث العائلي من الزوال
تحدي كبير يرغب الشاب في خوض غماره
كان لدي خبره وابيه او شدي كي يتعلم اكثر
احب الضغط على نفسي دائما من خلال
اعتبارهما اكثر خبره مني
طبيعيه جدا لان لهما ماضي ثري واشتغل في
مطاعم فاخره وانا لازلت متدربا
يقوم اليوم كليمو وفابريس وجاكي بامتاع
هؤلاء الذواق القادمين من بعيد للتلذذ
باطباق موسميه حيث احتلت في تحضيرها
التقاليد صداره الابداع
نحاول ان نبذل كل ما في وسعنا لاسعاد
الزبائن نحن طباخون ومهنتنا تتمثل في
تحقيق المتعدد لديهم هذا هو الاساس بس على
ان نكون الافضل لدى الناس اظن اننا كذلك
من بين المفضلين لدى الزبائن
منذ اربعين سنه تسطع نجمه بكل تالق في
سماء قريه
اربعه اجيال صنعت تاريخ مطعم صغير سجل
اسمه باحرف من ذهب في فن الطبخ الفرنسي